foreign
[Music]
Williams and I'm a senior data scientist
at the urban Institute
I make fake data for a living
and some scientific circles this would
be a huge Scandal but for me it's an
opportunity to further science
administrative data these are data that
are collected for reasons entirely other
than research like administering the
unemployment insurance system or
enforcing the tax code
are incredibly useful for research but
understandably have huge confidentiality
concerns
I work at the urban Institute we're a
collection of economists sociologists
criminologists urban planners and data
scientists committed to improving the
world through social and economic policy
research
we would do a lot to access
administrative data and we do do a lot
to access administrative data
but we understand that there's a
fundamental tension between accessing
these data and the confidentiality of
the data
that's why at the urban Institute we've
been working with the IRS to create
fully synthetic tax data
synthetic data are fake data that have
the statistical properties of
confidential data and can be used for
certain types of valid analyzes but have
much lower confidentiality concerns
because the data are fake you can think
of this as deep fakes for tax research
in this talk I'm going to try and make
the case that administrative data are
very useful but are difficult to access
I'm going to share how we're working
with the IRS to safely expand access to
administrative data for research and I'm
also going to talk about an r package
that we're developing that makes it
easier to synthesize data
administrative data are useful and I'll
give you two examples
the first example comes from March of
2020. it was a scary time when there was
a Health crisis and an economic crisis
unfolding at the same time
one issue though is that a lot of our
indicators for the labor market are
backward looking
and so there's one indicator one one
number that came from the administrative
data that I think painted an excellent
picture of the labor market
many people had never heard of it but it
ended up in a dramatic data
visualization on the cover of the New
York Times
this is initial weekly unemployment
insurance claims if you look at the
bottom left that starts in 2000 and it
bounces about uh you know from 2000 to
2020 and then there's this Black Swan
event that just shows how scary of a
time it was in our labor market
I'll give you another example
in 2013 Raj Chetty
um Emmanuel saez and co-authors released
groundbreaking research about
intergenerational mobility in the United
States using data from 40 million
anonymized tax records
this was really big research that deals
with how Americans see themselves right
we have that desire for our children to
be better off than ourselves
and one of the things that they found is
that place matters quite a bit
so for example the probability that a
child reaches the top quintile of the
national income distribution starting
from a family in the bottom quintile is
4.4 percent in Charlotte North Carolina
but 12.9 percent and hit San Jose
California I think I said Charlotte
North Carolina San Jose California
it's a really big deal
but some people say that this research
never should have happened
in a traditional model with an agency
like the IRS you do correspond its
research you have to get your analysis
plan approved you may never actually see
the data you send off your code they run
it on the data they review the results
and the like
what size and Chetty did was Radical and
different they actually became employees
of the IRS
they had to go through an extensive
background check have their fingerprints
taken go through lots of training have
all the results reviewed I've been
through this process and let me tell you
it's not pleasant at all
so the question is how can we get this
understanding this value this meaning
from administrative data
without all this inconvenience
all while protecting confidentiality
and that's why we're working with
synthetic data
if we can create fake data that match
the statistical properties of
confidential data
ways of safety validating the results
from the synthetic data against the
confidential data then we can
conveniently unlock a lot of this
potential
so we've worked with the IRS to create
two kind of one and a half data sets the
second one's still a bit of a work in
progress
the first one is called the supplemental
sin puff puff for public use file and
it's a collection of information that
the IRS has about individuals who
don't who have not filed taxes and do
not have an obligation to file taxes
it's a novel data set that's going to be
very helpful for understanding the very
low parts of the income distribution and
the tax economists that I work with are
pretty excited about it
now you may be asking yourself the IRS
what are all these non-filers doing in
here what about information that's
gathered at places that maybe have one
of these out in front of them and that's
the second file that we're creating it's
called the sinpuff and it's
representative of all taxpayers in the
United States
now the first file that I mentioned had
about 20 variables
this file has more than 200 variables
hundreds of thousands of observations
and it comes from a complex survey with
25 different strata
let's consider a much simpler example
for now where we have four variables and
two observations
so that's our confidential data set and
the setup of what we're trying to do is
create a new data set that has the exact
same record layout
we're going to employ a sequential
approach to create this data set so the
first thing we'll do is we'll sample sex
with replacement
then we'll create a predictive model to
predict age conditional and sex
then we'll create a predictive model to
predict wages conditional and sex and
age and finally a predictive model to
predict tax is conditional and sex age
and wages
it's a lot of predictive models
and this is where I get to express my
gratitude for tidy models and all the
people who have worked on this we heard
some great things about it this morning
tidy models is a comprehensive framework
for doing predictive modeling in arm and
we use it extensively and in particular
we use parsnip quite a bit which is an
interface to different machine learning
and predictive models and recipes which
is a really powerful package for feature
and Target engineering
now in the example that we're working on
right we need to do three predictive
models
I gave you another example we need to do
more than 200 predictive models so we
could imagine having an R script where
it's model one predict model two predict
model 3 predict
but if you're going to go all the way to
200 variables that's going to become a
real pain really quickly
so what tidy synthesis allows us to do
is actually specify a whole sequence of
predictive models for generating
synthetic data
it also allows us to do a few things
very specific to text or to data
synthesis
one is it allows us to add additional
noise to predicted values for extra
confidentiality protection
it allows us to specify constraints in
the data things like individual income
can't exceed family income or interest
income can't exceed your personal income
it also allows us to predict from our
models in different ways and I'll talk
about that more in a second
so simply put tidy synthesis the goal is
all the power of Tidy models for data
synthesis concisely with a few special
tools
so what does this actually look like I'm
going to show you how we're going to
synthesize a data set today
I'm not going to synthesize Unemployment
Insurance data to the relief of many of
you I'm not going to synthesize tax data
we could imagine synthesizing electronic
health records or maybe we're a business
and we're interested in unlocking
information from our customer data
without sacrificing the confidentiality
of any individual in our data but I'm
not going to do that either no instead
we're going to synthesize Penguins data
because Penguins deserve privacy too
so we're going to synthesize the Palmer
Penguins data set we already had a good
introduction to this earlier
right so we have information about
species and Island and sex and these
numeric measures uh measurements of the
different penguins and we're really
going to focus on these numeric
variables and our goal is to create
synthetic data that match the layout of
that confidential data
so we can start asking ourselves some
questions of what this should look like
if you have 200 variables
what order should we use well tidy
synthesis has a function that employs
different heuristics that you can use to
determine synthesis order
in this case I'm going to use my
extensive knowledge of penguins which is
absolutely none to determine that build
length is a very important variable and
then we're going to synthesize the
remaining variables in order from most
correlated with Bill lengths to least
correlated once we create this visit
sequence object it's going to be reused
in a lot of other functions
what kind of algorithms should we use
for our predictive models in this case
we're going to use a regression tree and
this is where parsnip really shines in
tidy synthesis so we just specify a
regression tree implemented with the r
part engine
now we need to specify that for all of
our different models and this is where
we're really saving on all that R code
in this case we just specify that we
want to use the r part mod for every
single variable there's three ways to
specify this the first one is like this
where we use the same model for all
variables
alternatively we can specify a default
and then override it for specific
variables or we can specify a different
model for every single variable
what types of feature or Target
engineering should we use
in this case this is where recipes
really shines in tidy synthesis we can
specify any set of steps in recipes for
our synthesis in this case we're not
going to use any feature of Target
engineering we're just going to use this
helper function construct recipes to
basically construct a series of formula
finally how are we actually going to
come up with synthetic data from our
models now if you just use the predict
function oftentimes you get a
conditional mean or a conditional median
this actually makes for really bad
synthetic data because the data sets
that you're creating don't have adequate
sample variants right you don't have
enough variation in the resulting data
so in this case we're going to use a
function called sample R part if you're
familiar with regression trees you
navigate to your final node and
oftentimes you might take the mean of
that node instead we're going to sample
from that final node to sort of get this
prediction distribution
so I just walked you through two of the
functions there's a lot of other
functions and objects and tidy synthesis
that can control the synthesis process
there's noise for adding additional
noise to predicted values there's
constraints for elegantly enforcing
constraints in the data and there's
replicates if we actually want to
synthesize more than one data set which
can be handled in parallel
tidy models is lazy right you create a
bunch of objects but a lot of the
computation doesn't actually happen
until you use like a tune function or a
fit function and tidy synthesis is the
exact same way so much like you have a
workflow in tidy models we have a
present object where we bring together
everything and then the actual hard work
starts when you run the synthesize
function this is where you go check
Twitter get your cup of coffee if you
have 200 variables maybe let it run
overnight
so I promise that we were going to
synthesize some penguin's data and I
have a quick video to show this off
and the right you'll notice we have
about 300 observations if we wrote all
this code out it might be a few hundred
lines of code but in this case it's only
about 70 lines of code
I'm going to highlight everything and
click run here in a second and you'll
see that it quickly gets down to the
synthesize function
now if you've worked with the Palmer
Penguins data set before I want you to
close your eyes and imagine what that
data set looks like this will take about
10 to 12 seconds to run
and now open your eyes unless you have
it perfectly memorized hopefully this
looks like what you were seeing in your
in your mind right
this looks like the Penguin's data set
but it's entirely made up it's entirely
fake
so we have synthetic data we're done
right if this is all I had to do I'd be
very happy I'd spend lots of time by the
pool with a drink and a you know the
little umbrellas and everything relaxing
but in reality I spend most of my day
saying have we done a good enough job
we can imagine looking at this in a few
different ways I mean on the surface it
looks like the Penguin's data set
we can look at the univariate
distributions for the four numeric
variables here I have density plots for
them where the synthetic data are in
blue and the confidential data are in
yellow and you see that we pretty
closely recreate the univariate
distributions for each of them and in
fact we only have 300 observations so
any differences here could just be
because of sampling error
we can also look at some bivariate
relationships here I have the
relationship between flipper length and
Bill length flipper length and build
depth and flipper length and body mass
again the synthetic data are in blue and
the confidential data in yellow and in
all three cases I think we do a pretty
good job of recreating the data and in
fact if you fit regression lines which
I've done here they look almost
identical
but maybe we're not satisfied
maybe we want to specify a new synthesis
and start all over again the good news
is we're not starting from the beginning
just like how in tidy models you can
reuse objects sort of over and over and
over again here we can reuse all of our
objects from earlier add some
information about adding noise to our
predicted values add some constraints
and synthesize
so just as a recap administrative data
are useful but difficult to access and I
think there's a huge potential to
understand more about our world if we
can make it easier to access those data
as a proof of concept we've created two
fully synthetic data sets with the IRS
and we've built this package called tidy
synthesis so that other agencies
non-profits and businesses can Implement
these methods without having to write
you know thousands of lines of code
now the data privacy Community the
synthetic data Community are pretty
small
and especially they don't have that many
statisticians or data scientists
so if this is something that gets you
excited if you're interested in joining
the raft of privacy penguins please
don't hesitate to reach out to me after
this talk here in person on Twitter at
aw underground or on GitHub maybe this
could be you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]